[Music]
that's the royal family gathering at
westminster abbey to remember the late
prince philip well we are expecting all
senior members of the royal family to be
in attendance at prince philip's service
of thanksgiving you'll recall the duke
of edinburgh's april 2021 funeral was
scaled back due to covet 19 protocols
fast forward a year later and the royals
are now able to pay their respects with
a larger group of those in attendance
prince george and princess charlotte
arriving with their parents prince
william and kate middleton george held
his father's hand as they arrived in
matching navy suits while charlotte
hand-in-hand with her mother wore a navy
dress code this marks one of the first
large-scale official events that the
eight-year-old third in line to the
throne and his six-year-old sister have
attended not making an appearance at the
service their younger brother
three-year-old prince louis but queen
elizabeth was there marking her first
major public sighting outside of windsor
castle and buckingham palace since last
fall and her recent health scare
accompanying her majesty her son prince
andrew who led her down the church's
aisle we are all feeling a great sense
of loss andrew's appearance definitely
raised some eyebrows after he was
stripped of his royal patronages
military titles and removed from royal
duties earlier this year amid his sex
abuse lawsuit and i feel very sorry
and supportive of my mother who's
feeling it i think probably more than
everybody else andrew's daughters
princesses beatrice and eugenie were
also there usually is very very close to
the queen another one of the queen's
sons prince charles and his wife camilla
the duchess of cornwall also paid their
respects that's charles sitting up front
next to his mother someone noticeably
absent prince harry i think a lot of
people are wondering why he can't be
there for such an important family
occasion et previously learned that the
37 year old duke of sussex would not be
attending as a preemptive safety measure
of course he had a very close
relationship with the duke of edinburgh
we understand the reason prince harry
won't be attending is because of
security and the situation as far as
harry is concerned is that he will not
have police protection over here and
therefore he doesn't feel safe bringing
his family over to britain but that
doesn't quite explain why he can't come
on his own a spokesperson for harry
shared that while the duke will not be
returning to the uk in late march he
hopes to visit his grandmother as soon
as possible we know that harry hasn't
seen the queen since last summer and of
course she's had a spate of ill health i
think most people are quite surprised
that he's not going to be coming over
here and so i think this is going to
further fuel talks of a continued rift
at the heart of the royal family and it
does raise questions i think about his
relationship with his grandmother once
so close and yet at that service of
thanksgiving prince harry won't be there
to support her or indeed to pay tribute
to his grandfather's life i think that's
probably a source of great sadness for
her majesty the queen
[Music]